You read a clue, and it seems to suggest something. You must assiduously avoid that line of thinking, because it's almost always trying to throw you off the scent. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 210, recorded on November 12th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Ben, we chat about Ben's C++ cryptic crossword. Well, let's do the crossword. Let me share my screen. I think I've got it. So, did you and Shima try it? I asked Shima if she wanted to partake and she said no.
你读到一条线索，它似乎在暗示什么。你必须坚决避免那种思路，因为它几乎总是想把你引入歧途。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 210 期，录制于 2024 年 11 月 12 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊 Ben 的 C++ 密码填字游戏。好吧，我们来做这个填字游戏吧。让我分享一下屏幕。我想我准备好了。那么，你和 Shima 试过了吗？我问 Shima 想不想参与，她说不想。
So this is a callback to what episode was it? We're going to go to the site and it says episode 201 when we were doing the CppCon recap. We put a link at the top of the show notes, which was to the C++ crossword that Ben made for the CppCon conference that happened back in September. And we said at some point we were going to come back, revisit this. I spent, admittedly, only 45 minutes attempting this. And half of that was spent with ChatGPT as well. Because let me tell you, folks, it was a struggle. I'm still not sharing my screen.
所以这是对之前哪一期的回顾呢？我们要去网站看看，上面写着第 201 期，当时我们在做 CppCon 的回顾。我们在节目说明的顶部放了一个链接，指向 Ben 为九月份举行的 CppCon 大会制作的 C++ 填字游戏。我们当时说，在某个时候我们会回来重温这个游戏。我承认，我只花了 45 分钟尝试这个。其中一半时间还是和 ChatGPT 一起度过的。因为我得告诉你们，伙计们，这太难了。我还没分享屏幕呢。
It's fair. Anyway, you know, when you're beginning, all roads to solutions are fair. There is no cheating here. I definitely did cheat. Okay. So you did use ChatGPT. And ChatGPT, let me tell you, was not helpful at all. In my experience, LLMs are not very helpful. For cryptics or just in general? For cryptics. Well, some point in are not very helpful for cryptics or just in general for cryptics well
这很公平。总之，你知道，当你刚开始的时候，所有通往答案的路径都是公平的。这里没有作弊。我确实作弊了。好吧。所以你确实用了 ChatGPT。而且我得告诉你，ChatGPT 一点用都没有。根据我的经验，大语言模型（LLM）在密码填字游戏方面，或者说在一般情况下，并不是很有帮助。是针对密码填字游戏还是泛指？针对密码填字游戏。嗯，在某些方面……它们在密码填字游戏方面，或者说在一般情况下，并不是很有帮助……针对密码填字游戏……
some point in general but especially for cryptics so i'm not sure if in episode 201 if we gave a cryptic crossword overview not not necessarily of this one but just in general but maybe because i used to be a crossword aficionado i I had the little, I got it from my grandmother when I was very young. It was this A to Z crossword, like, you know, hint book kind of thesaurus mixed with a dictionary mixed with clues. Used to love crosswords. I am terrible. And so I was pretty good at them.
在某些方面是泛指，但特别是在密码填字游戏方面。所以我不太确定在第 201 期我们是否给出了密码填字游戏的概述，不一定是针对这一期的，只是泛指。但也许是因为我曾经是一个填字游戏爱好者，我小时候从祖母那里得到了一个小册子。那是一本 A 到 Z 的填字游戏，你知道，就像提示书、同义词词典混合了字典和线索。我曾经很喜欢填字游戏。我很糟糕。所以我以前很擅长这些。
The point being, I am terrible at these cryptics. Anyway, so give us a little overview and we'll go through a couple of these. I'll walk through my thought process and then maybe you can try and help me. You can be my actual real life chat GPT and then we won't solve it all. We'll leave some of it for the listeners that haven't done this yet. So cryptic crosswords, the differences in the clues. So in a regular crossword like you might find in the New York Times or any newspaper in america north america they are caught they're what brits call quick crosswords which is where the clue is typically a straightforward synonym
重点是，我非常不擅长这些密码填字游戏。总之，给我们做一个简短的概述，然后我们过一遍其中的几个。我会讲讲我的思考过程，然后也许你可以试着帮帮我。你可以成为我现实生活中的 ChatGPT，我们不会把它们全部解出来。我们会留一些给还没做过这个的听众。那么密码填字游戏，线索的区别在于。在普通的填字游戏中，比如你在《纽约时报》或北美任何报纸上看到的那些，它们被称为英国人所说的“快速填字游戏”，即线索通常是答案的直接同义词。
of the answer right um now a cryptic crossword the clue is different uh but the clue always contains within it or practically always contains within it a a quick definition however the clue is designed to throw you off the scent. It's designed to suggest in your mind something which has nothing to do with the answer. Every clue has two parts. As I say, one part is the definition part, which will typically either be at the beginning or the end of the clue. The rest of the clue is wordplay, which when put together in the correct way will lead to the same answer as the definition. So that's the basics. But the thing you have to remember is you must never, you read a clue and it seems to suggest something.
对吧。嗯，现在，密码填字游戏的线索则不同。但线索中总是包含，或者几乎总是包含一个快速定义。然而，线索的设计目的是为了把你引入歧途。它的设计目的是让你在脑海中联想到与答案毫无关系的东西。每一条线索都有两部分。正如我所说，一部分是定义部分，通常位于线索的开头或结尾。线索的其余部分是文字游戏，当以正确的方式组合在一起时，会得出与定义相同的答案。这就是基础。但你必须记住的是，你绝不能……你读到一条线索，它似乎在暗示什么。
You must assiduously avoid that line of thinking because it's almost always trying to throw you off the scent. Okay. What instead you must do is consider each word, what it could mean and how they might fit together in wordplay. Anyway, so with that very brief introduction, go ahead, Connor, where should we start? Maybe what we'll do is I have two clues solved and then three or four or five that are guessed wrong. And so I did the ones that were guessed wrong.
你必须坚决避免那种思路，因为它几乎总是想把你引入歧途。好吧。你必须做的是考虑每个词，它可能意味着什么，以及它们如何组合成文字游戏。总之，有了这个非常简短的介绍，开始吧，Connor，我们从哪里开始？也许我们可以这样做：我有两个解出来的线索，然后有三、四个或五个猜错的。所以我做了那些猜错的。
I actually did first, but we'll come back to those because I don't actually know the solution. But I'll walk through my thought process as a former, you know, crossword doer, non-cryptic crossword doer. And I do know I have done a couple of these with Ben and Tristan before, and I'm not new to cryptics, although I've never solved probably more than five clues in my life. But so number six down, the clue is nerd with double E enthralled by database. And then it says parentheses five, which indicates it's five letters, which you could infer from just looking at the crossword. But sometimes it's two words and it'll give you like a two comma three. My thought process with this was that double E is supposed to mean electrical engineering or something from university. But it's a pun meaning that you're going to see two E's in this word.
我其实先做了那些，但我们会回头再看，因为我其实不知道答案。但我会以一个前填字游戏玩家，非密码填字游戏玩家的身份，讲讲我的思考过程。我知道我以前和 Ben 以及 Tristan 做过几个，我对密码填字游戏并不陌生，尽管我这辈子可能从来没解出过超过五个线索。但是，第 6 个纵向线索是：“nerd with double E enthralled by database”。然后它写着括号（5），表示它是五个字母，你可以从观察填字游戏本身推断出来。但有时它是两个词，它会给你写成类似“2, 3”的样子。我的思考过程是，double E 应该是指电气工程（Electrical Engineering）或者大学里的什么东西。但这是一个双关语，意味着你会在这个词里看到两个 E。
And I thought to myself, okay, nerd. Another word for nerd is geek. I don't know what database has to do with this. But I thought maybe I'll try geeks. And I actually, when I asked ChatGPT, it came to the same conclusion. So I'm as bad as the LLMs at least. It'll tell you all sorts of things. I typed in geeks.
我心想，好吧，nerd（书呆子）。nerd 的另一个词是 geek。我不知道 database（数据库）和这有什么关系。但我心想也许我试试 geeks。当我问 ChatGPT 时，它也得出了同样的结论。所以我至少和那些大语言模型一样糟糕。它会告诉你各种各样的东西。我输入了 geeks。
And then I checked if I was right and I got the middle E correct. And so I thought to myself, okay, that's not bad. So the classic, what you've done is fairly classic, right? You've seen something, there's some
然后我检查我是否正确，我猜对了中间的 E。所以我心想，好吧，那还不赖。所以，经典的……你所做的是相当经典的，对吧？你看到了一些东西，里面有一些文字游戏，有线索，你做了一个猜测。好吧。这是一个相当……里面有一些文字游戏，有线索，你做了一个猜测。好吧，这是一种相当正常的开始方式。现在你需要明白的是，你必须能够解释它。在一个好的填字游戏线索中，不会有任何多余的词。线索中的每个词都有其位置，要么在定义中，要么在文字游戏中。所以对于 geeks 这个猜测，好吧，double E 在里面。所以文字游戏的一部分在里面，它意味着 nerd，但它并不意味着 nerds。Geeks 是复数。所以这是一个问题。然后我们有这个“enthralled by database”，这是无法解释的。所以是的，geeks 是不正确的，因为我们无法……
wordplay in there, there's the clue and you've got nerd in there and you've made a guess. Okay. And that's a fairly's some word play in there there's the clue and you've got nerd in there and you've made a guess okay now that's a fairly normal way to start now what you need to appreciate is that you have to be able to explain it in a good crossword clue there will be no word which is superfluous every word in the clue has its place either in the definition or the wordplay. And so with the guess of geeks, okay, so double E is in there. So there's part of the wordplay in there and it means nerd, but it doesn't mean nerds. Geeks is plural. So that's an issue. And then we've got this enthralled by database, which is unexplained. So yes, so geeks is not correct because we're unable to, you know,
它不合适。这种情况很常见。就像有时你会做一个猜测，有时，就像这个例子一样，你会基于定义做一个猜测。所以定义引导你做出一个猜测，特别是如果你有一些交叉字母的话。然后你可以花几分钟弄清楚为什么它符合文字游戏。
it doesn't fit. And this is quite common. Like sometimes you'll make a guess, and sometimes, as in this case, you'll make a guess based on the definition. So the definition leads you to a guess, particularly if you have some crossing letters. And then you can spend a couple of minutes figuring out why it fits the wordplay.
但在这种情况下，geeks 不太对。所以继续吧。你的下一个是什么？嗯，我的下一个猜测是，我得承认，这些大部分我只是在扔飞镖，我甚至不知道飞镖盘在哪里。我只是希望我能……我甚至不知道飞镖盘在哪里，我只是希望
But in this case, geeks is not quite right. So carry on. What's your next? Well, so my next guest was, and I got to admit, most of these, I was just throwing darts and I didn't even know where the dartboard was. And I was just hoping that I would get, my even know where the dartboard was and i was just hoping
我能得到……我的策略，我们稍后会讲到五个字母的词，就是我把我知道的五个字母的 C++ 关键字都列了出来，比如 const，还有其他几个，float 我想，然后我去了，因为这个谜题里有很多五个字母的线索，我想其中一个一定是 const，所以我去找了几个我认为可能是 const 的，并试了一下，结果都不是。好吧，我其实并没有试所有的五个字母的线索，所以也许有一个，我只是没看出 const 怎么会是答案。总之回到 geeks，我知道如果……因为我检查了这个词，它告诉我第一个、第二个、第四个和第五个字母都错了。因为我猜对了一个 E，我就想，你知道吗？可能第四个字母也是 E。
that i would get my strategy which we'll get to for the five letter words was i went and typed out all the keywords in c++ that i know are five letters like const and uh there was a couple other ones float i think and then i went because there's a lot of five letter clues in this puzzle and i was like one of them's got to be const and so I went and found a couple that I thought could be const and would try it and none of them were well I didn't try actually all the the five-letter one so maybe there was one and I just couldn't see how const was a solution anyways back to geeks I knew that uh if the because I checked the word and it told me that the uh first second and uh fourth and fifth letters were wrong. And because I got one E right, I was like, you know what? Probably the fourth letter is an E as well.
所以我能想到什么词呢？因为第二个字母 E 错了。所以你认为它仍然有一个 double E。是的。第三和第四个字母。我想 double E，就像……因为我正在浏览线索，试图找到那些暗示变位词的。因为我的变位词技巧非常出色，
So what word can I think of? Because the second letter E was wrong. So you think it still had a double E. Yeah. Letters three and four. I think the double E, like, because I was going through the clues, trying to find ones that indicated anagramming. Because my anagramming skills are phenomenal
因为我玩拼字游戏（Scrabble）。有些线索会说，比如这个词在这个词里面，或者这个词是倒过来的，等等。所以这些是我过去能够解开的线索，基本上就是把一个词打乱，然后给它加一个字母。所以 double E，你知道，给了我希望。然后 nerd 也是一种糖果，所以我心想也许是 sweet，还是不知道 database 和这有什么关系，但你知道，它符合我的词形模式，所以我输入了 sweet，检查了这个词，我猜对了 W、E 和 E，但 S 和 T 不对。在这一点上，我心想，哈，像什么词？因为我相当擅长。我每天都玩 Wordle。我非常擅长找词。这是五个字母。这是 Wordle
because I play Scrabble. And some of the clues will say like the word is inside this word or the word is backwards or whatever. So those are the clues in the past that I have been able to solve is basically just like jumbling up a word and then adding a letter to it. And so double E, you know, is gives me hope. And then so nerd is also a candy and so I thought maybe it's sweet still don't know what the database has to do with this but you know it fits my word pattern so I type in sweet check the word and I get the W the E and the E correct but not the S and the T and at this point I'm like huh like, huh, like what word? Like, cause I'm pretty good. I play Wordle every day. I'm very good at finding words. This is five letters. This is, this is Wordle
中心。我心想，什么？T 也许放在第一个？所以我只是……我检查了 tweet，但是，你知道，不是 tweet，因为我本应该猜到的，我猜我本应该猜 tweet。因为它也行得通。在这一点上，我直接把它解开了，我不确定我们想怎么揭晓这个，如果你想走……我想因为我想我现在知道这个线索是什么意思了。好吧，所以继续吧。所以我……我想现在知道了解决方案，我们几秒钟后会告诉你解决方案是什么。线索是说 nerd 是主要线索。所以这是 nerd 的同义词。With double E 确实意味着里面有一个 double E。而 enthralled by，可能 enthralled by 意味着 double E 在 database 的两个字母之间。我不确定这是否完全正确，但这正是引导你得出所提供解决方案的原因。
central. I'm like, what? Like T maybe goes in first. So I just, I checked tweet, but like, you know, it's not tweet because I should have guessed, I should have guessed tweet, I guess. Cause that also works. And at that point, uh, i went and just solved it and i'm not sure how we want to reveal this if you want to walk i think because i think i know what the clue does now okay so go ahead so i i think uh now knowing that the solution uh what the solution is which we'll tell you in a couple seconds. The clue is saying nerd is the main clue. So this is a synonym for nerd. With a double E does mean that there's a double E in it. And enthralled by, probably the enthralled by means that the double E is in between two letters in database. I'm not sure if that's exactly it, but that's what leads you to the solution that was provided.
对。所以答案是 dweeb，意思是 nerd，对吧？是的，你跳过了几件事。所以 with 很重要。你知道，每个词都很重要。With 可以缩写为 W。所以它是 W-E-E，with W-E-E，W-E-E。正如你所说，它是 enthralled by，
Right. So the answer is dweeb, meaning nerd, right? Yeah, you've skipped over a couple of things. So the with is important. You know, like every word is important. With can be abbreviated to W. So it's W-E-E with W-E-E, W-E-E. And as you say, it's enthralled by,
它被包含在……围绕着 W-E-E-R 是 D-B，代表 database。现在我在这里有点随意了，因为其实我不认为 D-B 在字典里代表 database，但对于可能完成这个的人群来说，这可能刚好还可以。等等，所以 with？是的。With 应该是一个 W。With 可以缩写为 W，是的。这有字典支持。
it's contained within surrounding W-E-E-R is D-B for database. Now I'm being a little fast on loose there because actually I don't think D-B is in the dictionary for database, but it's common enough for the crowd that's likely to be completing this to be just about okay, perhaps. Wait, so the with? Yes. The with is supposed to be a W. The with is abbreviatable to W, yes. That is supported by the dictionary.
有字典支持。你刚才提到了两次字典。这是某种密码填字游戏的东西吗？如果你拿一本高质量的字典，通常用的是 Collins。不，不是 Collins。嗯，
Supported by the dictionary. You just made two references to the dictionary. Is this like a cryptic thing? If you take a good quality dictionary, the one that's usually used is Collins. No, not Collins. Um,
Chambers，Chambers。如果你在 Chambers 里查字母 W，其中一个定义会是 with，字母 W 可以代表 with，这是一个有效的缩写。它在
chambers, chambers. Uh, if you look up the letter W in chambers, it will, one of the, one of the definitions will be with the letter W can mean with it's a valid abbreviation. It's in the
字典里。哦，我不知道。是的，它在密码填字游戏中经常出现。你需要，就像在拼字游戏中一样，你需要知道所有的两个字母的词、三个字母的词等等，就像你刚才说的那样。在密码填字游戏中，你需要有一个庞大的库，因为，你知道，关于密码填字游戏有一个常见的误解，你不能仅仅把任何词缩写成它的首字母，它必须在字典里。所以我们可以说 W 是 with。W 还可以代表什么？Wife，那是一个常见的。还有什么 W 是……我在空白。W 并不是特别常见的一个，但有常见的。但是字母表的任何字母，大多数做密码填字游戏的人都能告诉你半打有效的缩写。我的意思是，这类似于其他的填字游戏。
dictionary. Oh, I did not know that. Yeah. It comes up a lot in cryptics. You need to, just like in Scrabble, you need to know all the two-letter words, three-letter words, et cetera, like you were saying. In cryptics, you need to have a large bank of, because, you know, it's a common misconception about cryptics you cannot just abbreviate any word to its initial letter it must be in the dictionary so we can say w is with w also what else would w stand for uh wife uh that's a common one what else is w uh i'm blanking w is not particularly one that's common but but there's common. But any letter of the alphabet, most people who do cryptics can tell you a half a dozen things which are valid abbreviations. I mean, it's similar to other crosswords.
有些词像 Oslo 总是出现，因为它们对于填满紧凑的小方格很有用。我想 weak，W-E-E-K，可能对 W 来说也是有效的。好吧。你知道，就像 S 代表 second（秒），M 代表 minute（分），H 代表 hour（小时）。Wide 也可以，因为它是板球得分。你在板球记分表上能看到它，对吧？所以你会看到 W 代表 wide，O 代表 over，M 代表 maiden，诸如此类，R 代表 run（跑）。这就是你需要作为密码填字游戏
There's certain words like Oslo that always come up because they're useful for completing little boxes of compact things. I think weak, W-E-E-K, would be valid for W probably as well. Okay. You know, just like S for second, M for minute, H for hour. Wide would be, because it's a cricketing score. You see it on the cricket score sheet, right? So you would see W for wide, O over m for maiden things like that r for run this this is kind of the bank of knowledge you need to have as a cryptic
解题者和出题者所拥有的知识库。是的，这就是密码填字游戏对我来说的问题，密码填字游戏依赖于跨文化、艺术和地理的知识广度，而我没有。所以很多时候它引用的东西，当我不认为……对于你在《纽约时报》等地方找到的许多填字游戏来说，情况并非如此，那些是经典的，因为你有如此密集的词汇映射，纵横交错，只要你知道术语，你就可以在某些地方缺乏知识也能过关。而这个游戏确实依赖于，就像，我只是没有的知识。它可能是某个国家的某条河流，我就是没有那种知识。但这个，你知道，有希望，因为它是 C++。
solver and setter yeah this this is the the problem with cryptics for me too is that cryptics rely on a diverse and like a breadth of knowledge across culture and art and geography that I do not have so a lot of this stuff sometimes that it pulls on like when I don't think it it is the same for a lot of crosswords that you'll find in like you know the New York Times which are the the classic ones a lot of those because you have such a dense, you know, mapping of words, crisscrossing, you can get away with a lack of knowledge in certain places as long as you know the terms. Whereas this really relies on, like, knowledge that I just, you know, it'll be some river. The clue will be some river in some country that I just don't have that knowledge. But this one, you know, there's hope because it's C++.
所以我们继续看 13 横向。我对这个很有希望，因为这里面有很多我理解了线索试图告诉我的东西。所以线索是：“pronoun taken back to contradict Jason Turner?”，括号（8）。是的。我的思考过程是，首先，
So let's, we'll move on to 13 across. I was hopeful for this because there was a lot in this that I got, I understood what the clue was trying to tell me. So the clue is pronoun taken back to contradict Jason Turner question mark and parentheses eight. Yes. So my thought process was well first of
我们知道倒数第三个字母是 b，因为它与 dweeb 相交，这就是我试图解开它的原因。所以 pronoun，我想是指代词，不幸的是，我的下一个想法是，我不知道有什么八个字母的代词，你知道，我把它们都过了一遍：he, she, they, her, him。所以 pronoun 不太可能是定义。所以不太可能……是的，taken back 对我来说意味着可能有一个词的倒置，这是一种文字游戏指示器。是的，我想如果我理解了线索结尾的意思，并且 contradict Jason Turner，我毫无头绪。而且我真的，在看到线索后，我本应该想到的。我问，当我问 ChatGPT 时，它说了一些关于 man 可以是一个代词，因为它是八个字母，它推理出 nobleman，
all and we know that the third last letter is b because it intersects with dweeb which is why i was trying to solve it so pronoun i thought refers to a pronoun unfortunately my next thought was there's no eight letter pronoun that i know you know i went through them all he she they her him so it's unlikely that pronoun is the definition uh so unlikely um yes and taken back to me means there might be a reversal of some word which is some kind of word play indicator yes i think if i understood the meaning of the clue at the end and to to contradict Jason Turner, I had no clue. And I really, after seeing the clue, I maybe should have gotten there. I asked, when I asked you at GBT, it said something about how man can be a pronoun and because it's eight letters, it reasoned its way to nobleman
以及如果把它倒过来拼写，它是如何符合的，并说 Jason Turner 只是一个误导。所以它显然甚至不理解密码填字游戏的概念，因为你刚才说一切都很重要。ChatGPT 说，哦，我们可以直接忽略 Jason Turner。你不能忽略 Jason Turner。Nobleman 不是答案。所以 Nobleman 倒过来也不是答案。所以我只到了这一步。
and how that, if you spell it backwards, fits and said that Jason Turner, it's just a misdirection. So it clearly doesn't even understand the idea of a cryptic because you were saying everything's important. He was, ChatGPT said, oh, we can just ignore Jason Turner. You cannot ignore Jason Turner. Nobleman is not the answer. And so Nobleman reversed is not the answer. So that's as far as I got.
然后在那一点上，已经过了 45 分钟了。我就想，你知道吗？我们直接揭晓吧。然后解决方案是，希望对于那些还没做过这个填字游戏并且正在跟着玩的人，你们可能有一些想法。解决方案是 YouTuber，当我看到时我很失望，因为 you 显然是那里的代词，它没有被倒置。但如果你把线索的其余部分倒过来，tuber，你会得到 rebut，我相信这就是 contradict 的映射。所以它是 pronoun taken back to contradict，所以你 rebut，然后你把 rebut 倒过来得到 tuber，然后线索……主要的线索是 Jason Turner，
And then at that point, it had been 45 minutes. And I was like, you know what? We're just going to reveal this. And then the solution was, and hopefully for those that haven't done the crossword and they're playing along, you might have had some thoughts. The solution is YouTuber, which I was disappointed when I saw because you clearly is the pronoun there, which is not reversed. But if you reverse the rest of the clue, tuber, you get rebut, which I believe is the mapping to contradict. So it's pronoun taken back to contradict so you rebut and then you reverse the rebut to get tuber and then the clue uh the main clue is jason turner
他是一位著名的 YouTuber。Jason Turner？问号在这里很重要。确实。因为 Jason Turner 是 YouTuber 的一个例子。Jason Turner 不是 YouTuber 的定义，但 Jason Turner 是……的一个例子，是 YouTuber 的定义，对吧？所以，你不能在不说这是个例子的情况下，从具体推导到一般。而这就是问号的作用。有趣。所以这里有一堆这种细微的策略，不是规则，而是，你知道，我假设你玩得越多就越能掌握的东西。
who is famously a youtuber jason turner question mark the question mark is important here. It is. Because Jason Turner is an example of a YouTuber. Jason Turner is not a definition for YouTuber, but Jason Turner example of is a definition for YouTuber, right? So, you can't clue from the specific to the general without saying this is an example. And that's what the question mark does. Interesting. So there's a bunch of this kind of nuanced strategy and not rules, but like, you know, things that you, I assume, pick up the more and more you play these.
是的，还有更多吗？因为我在 dweeb 线索或 dweeb 解决方案中错过了一些东西。在看到这里的解决方案后，我错过了什么吗？还是基本上就是这样？不，你略过了 with，但就是这样。我们看 14 纵向。这只是一个三个字母的条目。对。
And yeah, anything more is, because I missed some stuff in the dweeb clue or the dweeb solution. Did I miss anything after having seen the solution here? Or is that basically it? No, you skated over the width, but that was it. Let's take 14 down. This is only a three letter entry. Right.
我们知道它以 E 开头。对。因为它与 YouTuber 相交。线索是“appreciation of present delivered in bow”。三个字母。现在，这是线索的表面含义暗示什么的另一个例子，对吧？“Appreciation of present delivered in bow”。你想到的是一个包装精美的礼物，那里……这与答案毫无关系。所以我明白了，所以我不知道你是否用 ChatGPT 试过这个……我没有，当我看到这个时，我想 appreciation，因为我总是考虑文字游戏，我希望文字游戏会像字母的递增
Which we know starts with E. Right. Because it intersects with YouTuber. And the clue is appreciation of present delivered in bow. Three letters. Now, this is another example of the surface meaning of the clue suggests something, right? Appreciation of present delivered in bow. You're thinking about a nice gift wrapped item right there's that is entirely nothing to do with the answer so i see so i don't know if you've tried chat gpt with this one uh i did not i when i saw this i thought appreciation because i'm always thinking wordplay where i'm hoping for wordplay is going to be like the incrementing of letters
之类的。然后，但是，这说不通。这是一个有趣的机制，我以前从未见过，但它不适用于这种情况。然后当我读到“present delivered in bow”，我希望像，哦，线索是三个字母，in bow 意味着像我需要重新排列 bow 的字母，但因为里面有一个 E，那显然不是。好吧，所以你没走多远。这里的一个关键文字游戏指示器是 delivered。如果我 deliver 什么东西，我是在说它，对吧？Delivery 是一场演讲，我说的东西。
or something. And then, but like, that doesn't make a ton of sense. That's an interesting mechanic, which I've never seen, but it doesn't apply in this case. And then when I read of present delivered in bow, I'm hoping for like, oh, the clue is three letters in bow means like I need to rearrange the letters of bow, but because there's an E in it, that's clearly not it. Okay, so you didn't get particularly far. One of the key wordplay indicators here is delivered. If I deliver something, I speak it, right? A delivery is a speech, something that I say.
所以我们寻找的是一个同音词。这是一个常见的事情。所以 delivered in bow，我在大小写上有点随意了。Bow 真的应该大写。Bow 是伦敦东区的一个地区，这意味着我们正在寻找一个伦敦东区口音，考克尼（Cockney）口音的同音词。这在填字游戏中非常常见。当你看到暗示考克尼口音的东西时，你会想到去掉 H。所以我们寻找的是一个词，
So what we're looking for is a homophone. This is a common thing. So delivered in bow, I played a little fast and loose with capitalization here. The Bow should really be capitalized. Bow is an area of East London, which means we are looking for a homophone of something in an East London accent, a Cockney accent. This is very common in crosswords. When you see something that suggests a Cockney accent, you think about dropping H's. So what we're looking for is a word
意思是 present（礼物/现在），因为那是线索的另一部分。所以一个意思是 present 的词。如果伦敦东区的人说那个词，它听起来会像一个意思是 appreciation（欣赏）的词。现在，如果你是 present，你就在 here（这里）。Here，是的。如果你去掉 H，它是 ear。如果你有 ear for music，你就有 appreciation of music。所以 ear 意味着 appreciation。哦，天哪。这太令人震惊了。
that means present because that's the other part of the clue. So a word that means present. If someone from East London were to say that word, it would sound like a word meaning appreciation. Now, if you are present, you are here. Here, yeah. If you drop the H, it's ear. And if you have an ear for music, you have an appreciation of music. So ear means appreciation. Oh, my goodness. That is mind-blowing.
我以为你带 14 纵向是因为它会像，哦，这是一个简单的，让我们带你过一遍。你在开玩笑吗？所以那不是……我一点也没开玩笑。那正是答案。Bow 大写 B 是指不同大陆上一个国际城市的一个子管辖区。Appreciation for music 也被称为 having an ear for music，而 present 就像 here，这就是……我想如果你知道这些技巧的话。但这就像……太令人震惊了。这太令人震惊了，即使我听完你的解释已经理解了 85%，我仍然……直到你说去掉 H，那时我才明白。我当时想，
I thought the reason you brought 14 down because it was going to be like oh this is an easier one let's walk you through it are you kidding me so that's not talking i'm not kidding you at all that's exactly the answer bow with a capital b is a reference to a sub-jurisdiction of a international city on a different continent appreciation for music is also known as having an ear for music and present is like here and that's that's how anyone is i guess if you know the tricks of the tray but that is like mind-blowing that is mind-blowing even like i got 85 of the way listening through your explanation and i was i was still like until until you said drop the H that's when I got it. I was like,
那，那真是……哇。呜。好吧。所以让我们，让我们把它打出来。它是 E A R。对。
that is, that is wow. Woo. All right. So let's, let's type that in. It's E A R. Right.
天哪，我甚至没猜对，伙计们。我甚至没猜对。我甚至没猜对。我填的是 E R E。哇。我甚至，我甚至没猜对。
Oh my, I didn't even get it folks. I didn't even get it. I didn't even get it. I put E R E. Wow. I didn't even, I didn't even get it.
哇。呜。22 纵向相当简单。好吧。所以这个，这个是……所以它实际上，我注意到了这一点，但我打算用我以为的方式读它。本意是这样读的，但它可能是一个双关语，有多种发音。所以 22 纵向，五个字母，“lead carbon expert”。也可以读作“lead carbon expert”。
Wow. Ooh. 22 down is pretty easy. Okay. So this one, this one is, so it actually, and I noticed this, but I'm going to read it the way I thought it is. Meant to be read, but it could be a pun and there's multiple pronunciations. So 22 down, five letters, lead carbon expert. Could also be pronounced lead carbon expert.
所以我的第一个想法……这些想法很好。这些想法很好，对吧？你已经在试图穿透线索的含义了，对吧？并且在玩弄这些词。我的意思是，准备好失望吧，因为细微差别的深度，或者缺乏细微差别，或者缺乏深度，在这里会非常明显。作为一个编程语言的人，我看到 Carbon，我看到 lead Carbon expert。我想我知道所有领导
So my first thought- These are good thoughts. These are good thoughts, right? You're already trying to penetrate the clue's meaning, right? And playing with the words. I mean, be prepared to be disappointed because the depth of the nuance or the lack of nuance or the lack of depth is going to be very apparent here. So as a programming language person, I see Carbon and I see a lead Carbon expert. I think I know all the folks that are leading the
Carbon 项目的人。那些人是 Chandler Carruth, Richard Smith 和 Kate Gregory。或者至少在某个时间点，那是三个人。我知道他们现在有一个仁慈的团队，他们有轮换的人。但那是我知道的三个人。五个字母？那些名字里有五个字母的姓或名吗？Richard Smith？
Carbon project. Those folks are Chandler Carruth, Richard Smith, and Kate Gregory. Or at least at one point in time, those were the three people. I know that they have like a benevolent team for now, and they've got rotating people. But those are the three that I know. Five letters? Are any of those names five letters first or last? Richard Smith?
姓 Smith 有五个字母。把它放进去吧。我填了 Smith。每个字母都错了。你正中下怀。是的。你开始得很好。好吧，让我，让我们看看，鉴于每个词都很重要。
The last name Smith has five letters. Let's throw it in there. I put Smith down. Every letter is wrong. You fell fair and square into the trap. Yes. You started out so well. Well, let me, let's see, given every word matters.
对。所以其中一个词是定义。可能，我说通常定义要么在开头要么在结尾。Lead 或 expert。好吧，好吧，让我们回头再看。现在你必须像……你必须通过一个缩写和短同义词库来思考，对吧？Carbon 在密码填字游戏中可能是什么？可能不是编程语言。什么是有效的缩写？你认为 Carbon 可能缩写为什么？C。在元素周期表上，Carbon 是 C。对。现在，expert。
Right. So one of these words is the definition. Probably, and I say usually definitions either at the beginning or the end. So lead or expert. All right. right well let's come back to that now now you have to think like you have to think through a bank of abbreviations and short synonyms right what might carbon be in a cryptic crossword probably not the programming language what is a valid abbreviation what could what do you think might be what Calvin might abbreviate to? C. On the periodic table, Calvin is C. Yeah. Right. Now, expert.
Expert 可以是名词或形容词。就像，I am expert at something，那是形容词。是的。它可以是，是的。或者一个 expert，一个人……我们必须考虑我们对 expert 的同义词。现在，如果是名词，expert 可以是 ace。那会是一个相当常见的。潜在的是 pro，但有了 Carbon 代表 C，我们正在寻找其他四个字母。所以如果我们取 lead，现在我们知道 Carbon 是 C，我们正在寻找其他四个字母。所以如果我们取 lead，现在我们知道 Carbon 是 C，如果我们沿着这条线工作，它更有可能以 C 开头而不是以 C 结尾，对吧？所以我们想到 Carbon C 是第一个字母。然后我们需要一个四个字母的词
Expert can be a noun or an adjective. And like, I am expert at something that's an adjective. Yeah. It can be, yeah. Or an expert, a person.. So we have to think about our synonyms for expert. Now, if it's a noun, expert could be ace. That would be a fairly common. Potentially pro, but with carbon for C, we're looking for four other letters. So if we're taking lead, now that we know carbon for C, we're looking for four other letters. So if we're taking lead, now that we know carbon is C, it's more likely to begin with C than end with C if we're working on this line, right? So we're thinking of carbon C being the first letter. Then we need a four letter word
代表 expert，我们把它和 C 放在一起，定义就是 lead。现在你想到什么以 c 开头的五个字母的词可能意味着 lead，我们必须考虑 lead 或 led 的所有可能含义……嗯……lead，这对非英式英语使用者来说是一个棘手的词，因为 lead 的这个含义在英式英语中比其他地方常见得多。我的意思是，我并不是真的在考虑同义词本身，脑子里浮现的词是像 coach, champ 这样的，就像……对，你是顶尖的人，而那不是 lead 的正确含义。所以我只能告诉你，好吧，那个……如果我……lead 是一根电缆，什么？在英式英语中，如果你想买一根电缆，你会买一个 lead。哦，是的。当然，当我们看那个时，我们看到 Expert 作为形容词是 able。如果你是 able，你就是一个 expert。
for expert, which we put with the C and the definition would be lead. Now what five letter words beginning with c can you think that might mean lead and we have to think through all the possible meanings of lead or led right um uh lead this is a tricky one for non-british english speakers because this meaning of lead is far more common in brit English than than otherwise I mean I'm not really thinking of synonyms per se the words that are coming to mind are like coach champ things where like right you're the top person and and that is not the correct meaning of lead so I'm I'm just gonna have to tell you okay that um if i a lead is a cable what a cable in in british english if you wanted to buy a cable you would buy a lead oh yeah and of course when we look at that we see Expert as an adjective is able. If you are able, you are an expert.
对。我的意思是，我们快到了。我的意思是，我可能不会解开那个。我可能，你知道，在做了更多这些之后，至少会得到 lead Carbon 意味着第一个字母 C。这个，这个我其实以为是我最好的机会，我其实以为我有点懂了，但那是因为我……31 横向，也就是 cable 的最后一个字母，所以现在我们知道它以 E 开头，但当时我不知道线索，你得向我解释。好吧，向我解释你填了什么，因为我不确定我跟上了。我不能。好吧，让我们。
Right. I mean, we're getting there. I mean, I probably wouldn't have solved that. I would have potentially, you know, after doing a few more of these, would have gotten that lead carbon means the first letter C at least. This one, this one i actually thought was my best shot i actually thought i kind of got it but that's because i yeah 31 across which is uh the last letter of cable so now we know it starts with e but at the time i didn't know clue you had explain to me okay explain to me what you had in there because I'm not sure I follow. I can't. Well, let's.
哦，对。所以线索是“facility has run in with sensor”，括号（5），五个字母。所以这是我最初的策略。找到所有五个字母的关键字，或者只是与 C++ 相关的词。其中一个一定是某个地方的线索。Const，显然。当我想到 C++ 中的五个字母关键字时，那是我想到的第一个。Autos 是四个字母，consts 是五个字母。所以我看到了 facility，或者我读到，facility has run in with sensor。
Oh, right. So the clue is facility has run in with sensor, parentheses five, five letters. So this was my original strategy. Find all the five letter keywords or like words that are just relevant to C++. One of them's got to be a clue somewhere. And const, obviously. When I think of five-letter keywords in C++, that's my first one that comes to mind. Autos for four letters, consts for five letters. And so I saw facility, or I read, facility has run in with sensor.
我取了 facility 的字母和 sensor 的字母。把它们跑进彼此里面。你可以拼出 const。从 facility 和 sensor 的字母中。有一个 C-O-N-S。令人惊讶的是你可以。而且 facility 里有一个 T。我就想我得到了。我得到了，伙计们。
And I took the letters of facility and the letters of sensor. Running them into each other. And you can spell const. From the letters of facility and sensor. There's a C-O-N-S. Amazingly you can. And there's a T in facility. And I was like I got it. I got it folks.
是 const。我填入了 const。我只猜对了 S。我想我心想。那也许我的……我是对的，它是从 facility 和 sensor 的字母子集中变位出来的。所以我认为我试了几个，这就是为什么你看到，我不记得之前那里是什么了，但 O-N-S。然后我在最后试了一个 O。我真的不记得为什么。
It's const. And I put in const. And all I got was the S correct. And I think I thought to myself. That well maybe my. I'm correct that it is an anagramming from a subset of the letters of facility and sensor. And so I think I tried a couple, which is why you see, I can't remember what was there before, but O-N-S. And then I tried an O at the end. I can't really remember why.
所以我认为我只是试了几个不同的字母。但我现在只有 S。而且，还有，sensor 里有一个 E。所以我可能……我只是试了几个不同的字母，但我现在只有 S。而且还有，sensor 里有一个 E。所以我可能仍然是对的。但我现在怎么想呢？Facility 或 sensor 是线索。而且我们知道它是 E 空格空格 S 空格。是的。
So I think I just tried a few different letters. But all I have is now that the S. And also, too, there is a E in sensor. So I might I just tried a few different letters, but all I have is now that the S and also two, there is a E in sensor. So I might be still correct. What do I think now though? Facility or sensor is the clue. And we know it's E blank, blank, S blank. Yes.
所以简单地把 facility 和 sensor 中的一些字母混在一起。那不是一回事。嗯，它太模糊了，没有……线索里没有任何东西告诉你确切要做什么，所以虽然这是一个最初的想法，但它……它没有得到支持，对吧？我想……我想这就是为什么我试了 O，因为 O 是 S 的后续字母，或者与 S 相邻的字母，所以我心想也许 run in 意味着，你必须取连续的字母，你知道，来自每个词的。
So simply mashing together some of the letters in facility and sensor. That's not a thing. Well, it's far too woolly there's no there's nothing so there's nothing in this clue that telling you exactly what to do there so while it was an initial thought it's it's it's not supported right i think i think that's why i tried the o is because the o is the uh succeeding letter or the the letter adjacent to s and so i thought maybe run in means like it's a, you have to take contiguous letters and, you know, that are from each of the words.
但当我没看到那个时，我就想，好吧，那个想法显然是错的。所以再次，facility has run in with sensor。这让我想起了一个特定的形象，对吧？你必须绝对忽略它，对吧？相反，我们可以看，嗯，has run in 正在暗示文字游戏的一个元素，因为 run 可以缩写为 R，例如从板球记分表来看。Run 缩写为 R。
But then when I didn't see that, I was like, okay, that idea is wrong clearly. So again, facility has run in with sensor. This is bringing to mind a certain image, right? Which you must absolutely ignore, right? And instead we can look at, well, has run in is suggesting an element of wordplay because run can be abbreviated to R from a cricketing score sheet, for example. Run abbreviates to R.
所以解码这条线索的方法是说我们正在寻找一个意思是 facility 的词。我们要把一个 R 放在它里面的某个地方，然后我们要得出一个意思是 sensor 的词。A race 是正确答案。A race 怎么会是一个意思是 facility 的词呢？嗯，记住它是 ease，ease 是那个意思是 facility 的词，我们把一个 R 放在 ease 里，意味着 facility，是的。如果你有 facility with something，你就有 ease with it，你觉得它很容易。我想到的是 facility 是……我想是的，你在想 facility 的另一种含义，你在想像一个建筑物之类的东西，而这正是线索想要你思考的，因此你必须避免，对吧？好吧，我们还有五分钟或几分钟。你现在选一个你认为最容易解出来的吧。
So the way to decode this clue is to say we're looking for a word that means facility. We're going to put an R in it somewhere, and we're going to come up with a word that means sensor a race is the correct answer how is a race a word that means facility well remember it's ease ease is the word that means facility and we're putting an r in ease means facility yeah if you have a facility with something you have an ease with it you find it easy i'm thinking of the facility is that i think yes you're thinking of a different meaning of facility you're thinking of like a a building or something which is what the clue wants you to think about and therefore what
容易解出来的，或者……好吧，我们做 19 横向，因为 19 横向是签名。这是一个 15 个字母的词。那是一个容易解出来的吗？是的。它是一个 15 个字母的词这一事实意味着线索类型是更容易攻击的线索之一，对吧？因为一个 15 个字母的词，如果让它太难，那就会非常难。我作为解题者，作为填字游戏出题者的工作，不是提供一个无法完成的谜题，对吧？而是勇敢地失败，对吧？我想挑战解题者，但我希望他们能够得到答案，对吧？我的工作不是制造一个不可能的谜题。所以，特别是对于这些长的线索，对于一个 15 个字母的词，
you must avoid right okay let's we've got five minutes or a couple minutes left. How about you choose now one of the most, what you think is gettable ones. Gettable or, okay, so let's do 19 across because 19 across is the signature. It's a 15 letter word. That's a gettable one? Yes. The fact that it is a 15-letter word means that the clue type is one of the more attackable clues, right? Because a 15-letter word to make it too hard would just be very hard. My job as a solver, as a setter of crosswords, is not to provide an undoable puzzle, right? It's to lose bravely, right? I want to challenge the solver, but I want them to be able to get the answer, right? My job is not to make a puzzle which is impossible. And so, in particular, on these long clues, on a 15-letter word,
我想给解题者一个好的切入点，对吧？所以，开始吧。所以，我的意思是，线索读作引号。所以“quotation artful and quotation German import mag shows advanced technique”。15 个字母。现在，无论线索的表面含义似乎向你暗示什么，也许是稍微有点风险的含义，你需要把它从脑海中赶走。但同样，这是一个例子。这正是线索所做的。Artful German import mag shows advanced technique。
I want to give the solver a good in, right? So, go ahead. So, I mean, the clue reads in quotations. So quotation artful and quotation German import mag shows advanced technique. Fifteen letters. Now, whatever the surface meaning of the clue seems to suggest to you, slightly risque meaning perhaps, you need to put out of your mind. But again, this is an example. This is exactly what clues do. The artful German import mag shows advanced technique.
你可以考虑那可能是哪种 mag。但这与答案毫无关系，对吧？Mag 是 magazine 的缩写，对吧？是的。好吧。现在，线索的第一个词，artful。那可能意味着什么？它意味着与艺术或艺术性或艺术感有关的东西。
You can think about the kind of mag that might be. But it's nothing to do with the answer, right? Mag is short for magazine, correct? Yeah. Okay. Now, the very first word of the clue, artful. What might that mean? It means something to do with art or artistry or artistic-ness.
当然。而且它也意味着如果我们以一种 artful 的方式处理字母，我们可能会把它们混合起来并把它们变位。对吧？这是一个变位词指示器。它是吗？那很令人失望。它是。当你做填字游戏有一段时间后，对吧？它是变位词指示器。它是吗？那很令人失望。当你做填字游戏有一段时间后，
Sure. And it also means if we treat letters in an artful way, we might mix them around and anagram them. Right? It's an anagram indicator. It is? That's disappointing. It is. When you've been doing crosswords for a while, right? It's an anagram indicator. It is? That's disappointing. When you've been doing crosswords for a while,
你就会对这些事情保持警觉。任何暗示玩弄字母、使它们成为新的、改变它们顺序的词，任何类似的意思都变成了变位词指示器。在这种情况下，artful 是一个变位词指示器。如果你把 German import mag 中的字母加起来。我刚才在数。我当时想，German 里有六个，import 里有六个，mag 里有三个，也就是 15 个。
you're alive to these kinds of things. Any word that suggests playing with letters, making them a new, changing them around, any shade of meaning like that becomes an anagram indicator. In this case, artful is an anagram indicator. And if you sum up the letters in German import mag. I was just counting. I was like, there's six in German, there's six in import, and there's three in mag, which is 15.
我们有了变位词的原料。因此，定义必须是 advanced technique。当我们艺术地处理这些字母时，我们将展示一个意思是 advanced technique 的词。所以，你可以猜一下……import German mag，German mag，我们现在已经在 VS Code 中打开了我的关键字，用于……哦，这是对 Connor 过程的一个有趣的洞察。Import German mag，它是 15 个字母，而且它也意味着 advanced technique，对吧？Advanced technique。所以首先，有一个 ing。有一个 ing。
We've got 15 letters. So, we've got the anagram fodder. And therefore, the definition must be advanced technique. When we treat these letters artfully, we're going to show a word that means advanced technique. So, you could guess at it import german mag german mag we've now got vs code open with my key with my keywords for uh oh this is an interesting insight into color's process import german mag and it's a 15 and it's also it also means advanced advanced technique technique, yeah. Advanced technique. So first of all, there's an ing. There's an ing.
我们有15个字母，也就是变位词的素材。因此，定义必须是“高级技巧”。当我们巧妙地处理这些字母时，我们会得出一个意为“高级技巧”的词。所以，你可以试着猜一下，导入german mag，我们现在用VS Code打开了我的关键词，哦，这让我们深入了解了Color的处理过程，导入german mag，这是一个15个字母的词，它也意味着“高级技巧”，没错，高级技巧。首先，这里有一个ing，有一个ing。
It's a good start. Identifying prefixes and suffixes. Yeah, the number one common suffix probably spelled in Scrabble because you now only need to spell a four-letter or five-letter verb that can be uh ing there's three m's which i'm gonna guess uh two of those potentially are next to each other potentially it's gonna start with re but that that might not be the case there's only one e top i mean you can you can spell grammar, actually. Although now all my letters are gone from the beginning. So we got rid of the I, the G, the M. I-N-G. It does end with I-N-G.
这是一个好的开始。识别前缀和后缀。是的，拼字游戏中最常见的后缀可能就是ing，因为你现在只需要拼出一个四字母或五字母的动词，后面加上ing。这里有三个m，我猜其中两个可能挨在一起，也可能以re开头，但情况可能并非如此。只有一个e，我的意思是，你其实可以拼出grammar。虽然现在我开头的字母都没了。所以我们去掉了I、G、M。I-N-G。它确实是以I-N-G结尾的。
I can give you that. If you stare at this long enough. And again, you could use an anagram solver to solve this. That would be fair, certainly at beginner level, especially for one this long. The meaning is advanced technique. And we've got a c++ theme crossword so you might be able to guess it from that all right it's c++ themed i've totally
我可以给你这个提示。如果你盯着它看足够久。再说一次，你可以用变位词求解器来解这个。这很公平，当然是在初学者水平，尤其是对于这么长的词。它的含义是高级技术。我们有一个C++主题的填字游戏，所以你也许能从中学到它。好吧，它是C++主题的，我完全
forgotten that this was c++ themed uh i see the kind of the word memory but this is all just one word too 15 retro programming programming is good you can get programming out of that oh meta programming wow metaming we got is an anagram of german import mag i'm curious did you use a reverse or not reverse but they they have these uh uh yeah i used an anagram did you use that to get this or did you pick that out yourself i used an anagram generator okay um and i was you know i was so relieved actually i was i was like okay that's a 15 letter word i so my my thought process here was like i have a 15 word metaprogramming fits that's the first bit of serendipity um it's a good word it's a
忘了这是C++主题的了。我看到了memory这个词，但这整个也是一个词。15个字母，复古编程，编程很好，你可以从中得到编程。哦，元编程，哇，metaming，我们得到的是german import mag的变位词。我很好奇，你用了反转吗？不是反转，但他们有这些……是的，我用了变位词求解器。你是用它来得到这个的，还是你自己想出来的？我用了变位词生成器。好的，我当时真的很欣慰，我心想，好吧，那是一个15个字母的词。我的思考过程是，我有一个15个字母的词，元编程很合适，这是第一次巧合。这是一个好词，它是一个
good theme word which is what you want for these long kind of anchor things right so then i thought how am i going to clue this? I need to make the clue relatively easy. An anagram is one of the easy clue types, right? Because generally it's just an anagram puzzle. You don't need to think about different bits of wordplay plugging together. Then I went to an anagram generator on the internet and I typed in metaprogramming and I looked at all of the things it generated,
很好的主题词，这正是你想要的这种长锚点词，对吧？所以我当时想，我该怎么给它写线索呢？我需要让线索相对简单。变位词是一种简单的线索类型，对吧？因为通常它只是一个变位词谜题。你不需要考虑不同部分的文字游戏如何拼凑在一起。然后我去了互联网上的一个变位词生成器，输入了metaprogramming，看了它生成的所有东西，
and I saw something or something very close to German import mag, not necessarily in that order, but as soon as I found German import mag, I'm like, that's the best option. That's actually a good anagram, and then I can just put, and then I can construct the rest of the clue. That is, I think it's like once you know these tricks, right, the question mark that applies stuff, that letters or words can be shortened to letters. And that, you know, that's the thing is I know that some of the words that indicate like shuffling or anagramming, but I don't know all of them.
我看到了一个东西，或者非常接近German import mag的东西，不一定是那个顺序，但一旦我发现了German import mag，我就想，那是最好的选择。那确实是一个很好的变位词，然后我就可以直接构建线索的其余部分。这就是，我认为一旦你知道了这些技巧，比如问号表示的东西，字母或单词可以缩写为字母。而且，你知道，我知道一些表示洗牌或变位词的词，但我并不全知道。
I don't know that artful means that. But if I had all that stuff, I think I would get a lot for it. We should, I feel like when I asked easy to get one, you were hoping maybe for a fun one. Or is there like a one that is dealer's choice? Dealer's choice? Yeah, sorry. Let's see. Well, some are just cryptic, right?
我不知道artful意味着那个。但如果我有所有这些东西，我想我会得到很多。我们应该，我觉得当我问容易得到一个时，你可能希望有一个有趣的。或者有没有那种由庄家选择的？庄家选择？是的，抱歉。让我们看看。嗯，有些只是隐晦的，对吧？
Okay, so four down. Four down is four letters. Four down is four letters, yes. Partnership on fine wicket question mark. So I don't, wicket? I don't even, that sounds like something a basket is made out of. I don't even know what a wicket is. Partnership on fine wicket.
好吧，那么第四个向下。第四个向下是四个字母。第四个向下是四个字母，是的。Partnership on fine wicket，问号。所以我不知道，wicket？我甚至不知道，那听起来像是篮子是用什么做的。我甚至不知道wicket是什么。Partnership on fine wicket。
It suggests a cricketing. Suggests an afternoon of cricketing, right? Or it's a cricket item. A cricket is a... Oh, the things that they run around are wickets. The things at either end of the run. I see. This one, shall I just go ahead and explain it, deconstruct it for you?
它暗示了板球运动。暗示了一个板球下午，对吧？或者它是一个板球项目。板球是一个……哦，他们跑来跑去的东西是三柱门（wickets）。跑道两端的东西。我明白了。这个，我可以直接解释并为你拆解吗？
My guess is wife, but probably that's not correct. The wicket should really be capitalized. What does Wicket mean to you as a proper noun? Absolutely nothing. Have you seen Return of the Jedi? I have. I have seen all the Star Wars movies. Okay.
我猜是妻子，但这可能不正确。Wicket真的应该大写。Wicket作为专有名词对你意味着什么？绝对什么都没有。你看过《绝地归来》吗？我看过。我看过所有的《星球大战》电影。好的。
And so Wicket is the name of an Ewok. It is. The main Ewok, really. The one that leia befriends on the forest moon of endor i've lost uh nerd credibility there i apologize to everybody on the internet wicket question mark is the is the definition here so wicket is an example of an ewok ewok is the answer so how do we get partnership on fine how does partnership on fine somehow mean ewok partnership on fine so this is a down clue so on means on top of right in a down clue context clues differ slightly from an across clue because you can use words in the clue that indicate the physical placement of letters being above and below interesting that is something
所以Wicket是一个伊沃克人的名字。确实是。主要的那只伊沃克人，真的。莱娅在恩多森林卫星上结识的那只。我失去了书呆子的信誉，我向互联网上的所有人道歉。Wicket问号是这里的定义，所以Wicket是伊沃克人的一个例子，伊沃克人是答案。那么我们如何从Partnership on fine得到伊沃克人呢？Partnership on fine，这是一个向下的线索，所以on意味着在……之上，对吧？在向下的线索语境中，线索与横向线索略有不同，因为你可以使用线索中的词来表示字母在物理位置上是在上方还是下方。有趣，那是
where down clues can differ from across clues so fine i was thinking of as a penalty but it's fine as an okay okay yeah should have been obvious fine and then and then ew how does that mean partnership ew partnership it's an abbreviation for something that's not coming to me this is this is east and west east and west our partners in the game of bridge wow i want to i might put a poll out when this podcast released in three weeks of how many folks know that wicket is an ewok i wonder how many of the you know developers and nerds that uh follow me because uh i'm a i'm a star wars fan i've seen actually most of the john favreau and um the guy that did mandalorian and all the animated stuff i've seen all of, but I have not retained the knowledge of the name of the Ewok.
向下线索与横向线索不同的地方。所以fine，我把它想成罚款，但它是fine作为好的，好的，是的，应该很明显是fine。然后是ew，那怎么意味着合伙关系？ew合伙关系，它是某个东西的缩写，我想不起来了。这是东和西，东和西是桥牌游戏中的伙伴。哇，我想，当这个播客在三周后发布时，我可能会发起一个投票，看看有多少人知道Wicket是一个伊沃克人。我想知道有多少关注我的开发者和书呆子知道，因为我是一个星球大战迷，我实际上看过大部分乔恩·费儒和那个做曼达洛人和所有动画东西的家伙的作品，我都看过，但我没有记住伊沃克人的名字。
Anyway, we'll plug that in. This has been, this has been, this does make me want to get more into cryptics. I know you've been, you've been slowly working on me over the last couple of years. Well, it's one of those things that they are impenetrable at first glance, but I think you have enough tools now. And the vital thing is like you can guess at the answer, but you must then go back and explain every part. In a well-constructed clue, it will be, every part will be explained
无论如何，我们会填进去。这确实让我想要更多地了解隐晦填字游戏。我知道过去几年你一直在慢慢引导我。嗯，这是那种乍一看深不可测的事情之一，但我认为你现在有足够的工具了。最重要的事情是，你可以猜测答案，但你必须回头解释每一部分。在一个结构良好的线索中，每一部分都会被解释
and every word in the clue will be significant. Yeah. And it's the first and last. Final question. I was going to say it's the first and last, you know, words of the clue that are the most important. But final question before we go. Is const in this? Const is not in this puzzle. That was my mistake. I can tell you which of the, if you like, I can tell you which of the words are theme words. Okay. If that would help.
线索中的每一个词都将是有意义的。是的。这是第一个和最后一个。最后一个问题。我本来想说这是线索的第一个和最后一个词，它们是最重要的。但在我们走之前最后一个问题。Const在里面吗？Const不在这道题里。那是我的错。如果你愿意，我可以告诉你哪些词是主题词。好的。如果那有帮助的话。
Sure. So, let's see. Eight across is a theme word. One down is kind of techie theme. 32 and 32 across and 29 across are both theme words let's see and i i guess maybe the thing to point out is that some of these are are only peripherally like kind of tacker nerd adjacent it's not necessarily like everything is a c++ um yeah like clue and solution kind of thing c++ knowledge helps with this puzzle and also
当然。那么，让我们看看。第八个横向是一个主题词。第一个向下有点技术主题。32横向和29横向都是主题词。让我们看看，我想也许需要指出的是，其中一些只是外围的，有点技术书呆子相关，并不一定意味着所有东西都是C++，是的，像线索和解决方案那种东西。C++知识对这个谜题有帮助，而且
hurts in some way because firstly some of the words are c++ adjacent some of the answers but but none of them are particularly specialist terms to c++ apart from perhaps metaprogramming but also some of the clues have suggestions in them which of of course are red herrings. And they might suggest things to people who are a favorite C++, which turn out not to be part of the answer. For instance, two down has Matt Godbolt in it. Yeah, Jason Turner, Matt Godbolt.
在某种程度上也有害，因为首先有些词是C++相关的，有些答案是，但它们都不是C++的特别专业术语，除了元编程。而且有些线索中有暗示，当然是红鲱鱼。它们可能会向那些喜欢C++的人暗示一些东西，结果发现并不是答案的一部分。例如，第二个向下有Matt Godbolt在里面。是的，Jason Turner，Matt Godbolt。
All right, this has been a blast. Link for those that are interested will be in the show notes. We will have to record again because I know you had thoughts on some of the things that were in episode, excited about the board games. We were going to talk about APL a bit, but that'll have to wait. Anyways, until next time, yeah, hopefully folks enjoyed a slight variation in the content. But clearly, we see board games and puzzles and stuff, and we end up chatting way longer than we planned. This is how things go, yeah. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening.
好吧，这太棒了。感兴趣的人的链接将在节目说明中。我们将不得不再次录制，因为我知道你对剧集中的一些事情有想法，对棋盘游戏很兴奋。我们本来要聊聊APL，但这得等下次了。无论如何，直到下次，是的，希望大家喜欢内容上的轻微变化。但很明显，我们看到了棋盘游戏和谜题之类的东西，我们最终聊的时间比计划的长得多。事情就是这样，是的。请务必在你的播客应用程序或ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti Bryce. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。我是反布莱斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。